central bankers and politicians have
been absolutely gaslighting americans
for months now if we go back 18 months
ago or so in march of 2020 there was
absolute hysteria this thing called
kovid was taking over and governments
were stepping in and forcing their
citizens to lock down saying go home and
do not come out of your home it's for
public health reasons of course when
that occurred all of a sudden investors
in financial markets got very very
scared there was uncertainty there was
fear so what did they do they sold off
every single asset they had that had a
liquid market attached to it there was a
liquidity crisis and they wanted dollars
gold went down 15 percent stocks went
down 25 and bitcoin went down 50
all in a very short number of days in
march of 2020. as soon as that occurred
just as in 2008 global financial crisis
the government central bank stepped in
with absolute monetary and fiscal policy
bazookas they lowered two emergency
interest rate cuts all the way down to a
zero rate environment and there was
trillions of dollars of monetary and
fiscal stimulus that was injected into
the economy in every exotic corner they
could find they were literally dropping
helicopter money on people they were
giving out unemployment booster benefits
and on top of that they were buying so
many bonds that they literally got tired
of it
now when this was all occurring the
storyline was don't worry about
inflation inflation isn't going to
happen there's a deflationary macro
force here do not worry inflation is not
something that we're concerned about
and then towards the end of 2020 they
started to talk about well
we still don't think inflation is here
but maybe it could happen and then in
the beginning of 2021 into april or may
and even june of 2021 people say wait a
second isn't inflation happening we're
seeing more than two percent inflation
what's going on and then they started to
talk about and say it's central bank
level that's because we want it we want
there to be over two percent inflation
for some period of time but then by the
time we got to july august september and
october we started to see five plus
percent cpi numbers and then six percent
cpi numbers and then we saw president
biden his new administration go ahead
and raise their inflation target from
two percent in q4 of 2021 to 4.8 percent
they more than two and a half x their
own inflation expectations the entire
time you were told do not worry about it
this is transitory it's transitory and
it's transitory
well now today jerome powell is on the
stand he is
talking about this he's being asked
questions but politicians we got a
couple of comments that he made that are
quite interesting remember it's
transitory don't worry about it
inflation is not here to stay
the first one is that jerome powell
started out and he admitted that there
is a higher risk
of higher inflation that's exactly what
bitcoin has been warning about the
entire time
bitcoiners were screaming and yelling
saying you cannot print trillions and
trillions of dollars and not have
adverse effects but jerome powell now
saying wait a second even though we have
6.2 cpi there is a risk of higher
inflation and that risk is increasing so
rather than it being transitory rather
than it tapering off instead what we're
seeing is the potential to accelerate
inflation if the official numbers are
saying 6.2 percent the unofficial
numbers are showing over 10
pretty scary stuff but he wasn't done
yet he had more stuff to say the second
tweet that we have here was inflation
was never transitory nobody who
understands economics actually thought
it was transitory it was all a game they
were just gaslighting you you can't
create trillions of dollars of liquidity
and not have adverse side effects but
now they are being forced to admit it
you could only say it's transitory for
so long and as we have talked about over
and over and over again on this show
transitory was a very specific word that
was used because it's not measurable
what is transitory is it days is it
weeks is it months is it years nobody
knows at what point do we hit transitory
at what point do we come off of
transitory nobody knows it is not a
quantifiable metric and that's the whole
point is that you can move the goal post
without ever anybody noticing except for
we have the internet and we have social
media and there's people who can think
for themselves the independent thinkers
those who come from a first principle
standpoint those who understand austrian
economics kept calling nonsense they
said this is not possible what you're
talking about makes no sense i don't
care what textbook you read i don't care
what college professor you talk to or
what economics expert you brought in to
give you a 200 000 talk you're wrong
and now we're seeing the market
determine the same thing because the
federal reserve chairman jerome powell
today suggested that we stop using the
word transitory it's a big deal no
longer do they want to use the word
transitory when speaking about inflation
he said quote i think it's probably a
good time to retire that word
and try to explain more clearly what we
mean it was never transitory they knew
that i knew that everyone knew that they
simply are just gaslighting now they
told you not to worry about it then they
told you their goal was a little bit
over two percent then they told you that
it was transitory now they're telling
you it's good for you
maybe we should stop listening to them
maybe we should actually start just
looking at the data ourselves and
realizing that the official numbers are
wrong but even if you give them the
benefit of the doubt and say that the
official numbers are right
they're even having to admit now it was
never transitory inflation is here it's
here to stay it's likely to get worse
and if you don't understand how
inflation works if you don't understand
what the relationship to money is if
you're saving you're losing savers are
losers in this economy the advice that
your grandparents or your parents gave
you about spend less than you make and
just put it all in cash in the bank and
one day you'll save enough and then
you'll become rich
they were right for their generation
today's environment you can't do that
because quite literally your cash is
losing six percent every single year
it's the only investment in the world i
know where you're guaranteed to lose
value and people still rush in and hold
it
how big of a deal is it that he wants to
retire the word transitory he doesn't
want to use that anymore it makes me
nervous that they knew
everything that was going on the entire
time and they didn't tell people about
it
it's clearly not transitory it never was
transitory i believe that they knew
personally that it wasn't but they had
to kind of put on the face for the
american people powell knows what
creates inflation and printing trillions
and trillions of dollars does not help
um and they can't stop they're going to
have to continue to print money
so i just uh
just for
some fun here i googled transitory just
to get the official definition
uh it says it is temporary or not
permanent and and the point why that's
important is because they use that word
for a reason right you can't hold them
to a time period when you say that word
it could have been a month it could have
been six months it could have been a
year maybe even two years who knows
right you can you can make an argument
that transitory could mean any amount of
time that's possible so that word was
used on purpose because it didn't hold
them to a time period great got it but
when you look at uh the federal reserve
how do they get this wrong right like
you either intentionally misled people
by lying to them and telling them that
you thought it was transitory and you
thought it was going to go away or you
missed it right and it's hard to believe
that they missed it because people on
twitter bitcoiners were literally
yelling for months non-stop saying
inflation is coming you guys introduced
40 of the money supply has been
introduced or printed within the last 12
to 24 months inflation is coming yeah i
i looked it up earlier the federal
reserve has 23 000 employees and they
own over 3 billion worth of real estate
in this country that's how big they are
it's massive it's massive and you're
telling me that they didn't know that
the money printing that they were doing
was going to lead to seriously higher
prices and the loss of purchasing power
for millions of americans i don't buy it
and the only other logical explanation
is that they lied about it
john when you start to look at this do
you think that there's another word that
is better to use for it or do you think
that now they're just going to say
inflation is here insane
like out of control there's a million
different things but transitory is just
not the word i'm looking at the fed
balance sheet now it's almost nine
trillion dollars
i think we might get there by the end of
the year they keep printing money and
they pass more and more bills um but
yeah no transitory is just not the word
to use here i'd have to sit down i'm
sure they sat down and had kind of
brainstorming sessions about what do we
tell people do we tell them that we
expect it really high like how do we
basically phrase it in a manner that
wouldn't panic people uh but would get
the message across and i think they
missed the mark on this one
the
big thing
that uh i think is important to call out
so uh just now josh wolfe uh who is a uh
venture investor at lux capital he just
tweeted out a screenshot of uh a
financial times uh article which by the
way the the people who write at the
financial times uh they've turned that
thing into tmz or the financial
i mean the financial times is an
absolute [ __ ] show and i don't care if
you work there or not it's a complete
[ __ ] show if you work there please quit
like just go please go to another
publication that is better uh but
the thing that josh wolf has said is he
said be warned an entire generation a
growing percent that are quitting their
jobs and day trading stocks or crypto
has not seen a downturn a graduate of
college in 2019 now age 35 has seen
nothing but up markets
and uh i think there's two things about
this one not true right literally they
lived through a recession last year so
there was a recession last year that
everyone lived through second is that i
responded i said bear markets have been
outlawed by politicians and central
bankers the market is manipulated and it
is literally impossible for the market
to go down when they are willing to
intervene with monetary and fiscal
stimulus every time we get a few days of
prices falling and i think that's a key
piece to this whole thing is that we
don't live in a free market the free
market is literally uh being manipulated
and intervened in every single time that
we even come close to having a week of
down prices we have to have all up
all-time highs all-time highs over and
over and over again right yeah and i
think that's the the funniest part when
people claim that bitcoin is manipulated
right it's the it's the most honest
market we have and plenty of people have
said that in the past but it's true and
the reality is right like what happens
in the economy not only they print cash
they can simulate they can buy bonds
they can do all these things mess with
mortgages they can do a million
different things right the halt trading
if a stock isn't going their way
the rules are not fair for everyone and
they can manipulate the market at their
own will bitcoin is completely the
opposite it's a 24 7 market it's
decentralized it trades uh freely openly
et cetera it is the most honest market
there is and knowing no one is
manipulating it like the federal reserve
is with the infusion of cash and all
this stuff so i think when you talk
about uh politicians and people that are
saying these outrageous things they need
to be called out on this stuff because
what it comes down to is that the market
that we have here the stock market the
equity market here in the united states
is more way way way more manipulated by
the federal reserve and others than the
bitcoin market is
i agree with that but do you think that
bitcoin is a beneficiary of it or do you
think that bitcoin is the leader of it
like are they doing is bitcoin being uh
uh advantageous or like capturing the
value of what they're doing just like
every other asset or is bitcoin actually
the one that's kind of uh leading it and
then they're reacting to things that are
happening in in the free market the
honest market wait so you're asking
basically if bitcoin is benefiting from
them manipulating the other market
yeah like basically bitcoin can serve as
either oh all asset prices are going up
in bitcoin just benefits or bitcoin is
outside of the system and people are
running to bitcoin because they believe
that they're going to manipulate the
market so bitcoin is the leading
indicator like is bitcoin following the
actions or is bitcoin leading into well
i think one of the things to think about
too is just the amount of money that was
injected into the system right and
bitcoin we all talk about this all the
time right like there is a constrained
amount of supply uh and when you have
that fixed supply or constraint supply
and we know exactly how much is out
there when you inject all this money you
print all this money and then everyone
gets scared of inflation what do they do
not only they have more money to go
invest in things but they have they're
they're all looking for an inflation
hedge and i think that's why we've seen
the stock market has obviously benefited
a lot over the year from that also but
bitcoin has benefited tremendously and
that's the argument between bitcoin and
gold right because gold uh would
typically be that inflation-hedged asset
but it hasn't been over the past year
it's actually down or even for the last
year and bitcoin has been benefited
tremendously i think from that money
printing and people saying hey look this
is a much more fair and honest market
than the stock market probably is yeah
and people forget there was a recession
literally 18 months ago yeah like a
two-month recession and it was over just
but again but there was still a
recession right there there's still a
recession literally why did it end so
quickly because because they stepped in
and intervened and went nuts and so
literally when you say things like an
entire generation has not seen a
downturn like they literally saw stocks
fall 25
in a couple of days and on top of that
it was qualified as a recession there
was 14 million americans that lost their
jobs or i'm sorry 14
unemployment rate there was six million
people a day a week that was filing for
first-time unemployment claims for
multiple weeks in a row literally their
businesses were shut down it people
thought we were going to the great
depression until they stepped in
now we have people quitting their jobs
crazy crazy absolute craziness